hey guys it's Justine and today we're
gonna be doing a house tour of my anal
crossing house let me show you the
outside it's been a while since you've
actually seen this I made a video that I
never even posted doing a redo of my
house so I'll show you guys what it
looked like before
um this is what happens I just dropped
everything that I had there's not even a
single bit of space to put anything else
is there a pizza kind of food is in that
oven this is I don't know I have no idea
I haven't even gone into my other room
yet let's just let's just go in and see
what's up
a new fresh room to do whatever I want I
have so much stuff in my storage where
we're at today you did see my Island
tour and if you didn't already up the
link in the description you can go check
that out and see the rest of my Island
but I just love this view and it's
starting to get dark and it also Sun is
going down but we're gonna go check out
my house I'll show you some of the
things that I've got going on I haven't
really touched much inside of my house
lately so this is a present for my
podcast that I'm doing about Animal
Crossing of course this is my little
house so we've got a lot of stuff going
on here I mean I don't even know what's
happening anymore I just started finding
cool stuff and then I just started
putting it everywhere but my main
favorite thing is this throwback skull
radio well I can't get it because it's
on top of the chest so clearly I just
have to hope for the best
let's change the song first of all well
it's just to a basic everyday welcome
her hi it's like since the beginning
this has always just sort of been a
living room slash bedroom I do need to
do a complete overhaul of my house
because every time I got a room I just
kinda started throwing stuff into it so
this was the only one that I really
spent a lot of time on and then we have
this little area over here this was I
don't know this was like a bathroom
slash then I promise you nothing makes
sense here at all like what is happening
I've got a skull floor to skull
wallpaper I have all of my awards for my
happy home Academy my bathroom got a
nice little lounge area on the fireplace
yep it's kissing me
I do like this light that was is cool
everything looks cooler with the lights
off though so I accidentally made my
Island on the southern hemisphere so I
didn't get any of the cherry blossoms so
Jenna made me this wall this is the DJ
set right here in the center of the room
I've got my animal crossing switch over
here if I can see it right there
I love this gears thing I just got that
from a balloon yesterday this is in a
little workshop area got my little pink
mantis here that missus name flip I
always forget his name
bug dude comes in here creeping I just
got this - that knife board I thought I
would put it above my bed because why
not i want it to be realistic since in
my real home had some party decorations
there this is gonna be sort of my
shooting area but now that have a
basement that's not being used I think
I'm gonna move the studio downstairs I
have a couple other lights that I'm
gonna add to here this is the office I
want to get something cool over here
like a bit of a laptop there's got to be
like another pink laptop somewhere and
clothes that you don't see much holes
see I had this there's so much stuff
that I can do with this
I made this back when Tiger King came
out that feels like a year ago at this
point but it was my tiger king room I
won Miss on a fish what's it called a
fishing tournament I got all my soup's
on I'm really sure there's my birthday
cake that they gave me when the game
came out on my birthday when I was born
teamed make some toast I also have a
pink fridge now - I have a lot of pink
stuff that I need to update
that's why I'm on the hunt for I'm on
the hunt for all of the items that are
pink and I haven't got any like
cataloguing events so I really haven't
been able to get a lot of stuff all of
this stuff is but either like my friends
have given me or I've bought I've got
from balloons so all of this stuff is
pretty much over hundreds of hours of
shaking trees and just doing dumb things
but to everybody who has given me some
things I'm super grateful Emily gave me
that TV and this phone and actually I
think she gave me this bear as well
I had these other bears like that big ol
bear fell from a freaking balloon one
day and
I about lost my mind he didn't a little
workout area make it in there I'm sure I
can because I just put this in today
actually there we are here we go
get okay get out you're done there this
room is also just kind of thrown
together it was just stuff that I kept
getting so I kept putting it up here I
can't reach the TV from here can I can't
mini fridge no I'm not gonna change in
the fridge but thank you but this room
has a lot of potential when I get some
time to re decorate it I just need some
items like I don't have stuff to put
like all the stuff I have is just weird
weird things the basement dough fry my
favorite and it has some turnips down
there is where the t-rex resides in some
extra turnips gotta sell these turnips
before they spoil thought I'd put the
crowd back there cheering on I think
this is the swamp flooring I really like
that that's my house tour lots of things
lots of potential but this is what I've
been doing with my time so that's really
it I wonder if it's dark yet so you guys
can see the nighttime view really want
to get some cool lights up there though
okay it's starting to get dark but not
quite
wouldn't this dark those all light up I
have like some cool floor lights so it's
all flooded and looks really neat so
that's it I will see you guys in my next
video if you guys wanna see more Animal
Crossing let me know if you would like
me to do a live stream I've been
thinking about doing that as well I will
uh I will see you guys later
sure to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram because that's probably where
I will post if I do decide to do a live
stream and where I decide to do it it
will be linked to there plus you guys
later and that's it that's the end of
the video
[Music]